-Fred Armisen, welcome back to
the show.
Thanks so much.
-How's it going?
-It's going fantastic.
It's going great.
-You know what's --
I saw you backstage.
We were talking with
David Blaine,
and I didn't know you guys knew
each other.
Congrats.
-Thanks. Yeah.
-Your friends with a lot of
famous people,
but we were talking and then you
actually said that
you're getting into magic.
-Yeah, I started doing magic
myself a little bit, and so I'm
going to do a little bit
for you now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But, you know, David Blaine is
coming on the show.
He's doing a trick for us
later on.
He's one of the greatest
magicians.
-But that's like another level.
This is me
starting to get into it
and to get the feel for it.
But you can all see this, right?
So, Jimmy, I'm going to need
your help with this.
-Yeah, wow.
-Who was the first President of
the United States?
-George Washington.
-So, here he is. Okay.
And he was the first one,
so that is one.
Okay. So, you see there.
-Uh-huh.
-So, he was the first president.
-Oh, yeah.
-And after him came
a second president.
So, we're going to do this
twice.
-Ooh, I think --
-Second president.
And so, when is your birthday?
What the number of
your birthday?
-Say it out loud?
-Yeah.
-19.
-19. Okay.
So, one. Okay?
And then a ninth of this, okay?
So --
[ Laughter ]
-1/9th.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
So, that's a ninth.
-1/9th of the dollar.
-Okay. Right.
[ Laughter ]
-So -- Alright.
So, the third president -- So,
the third President isn't here.
Why? Because he's not here.
-The third president
is not with us.
-No? Okay. Nor is the fourth.
So, we can see there isn't
a fourth president here.
-Uh-huh.
-Okay.
And so, what is the month of
your birthday?
[ Laughter ]
What's the month?
-It is this. Nine.
-Nine. Okay.
So, we had the ninth before,
so we've got this here.
And then --
-Yep.
-Now.
-Uh-oh.
Nine.
-Okay. So, we got nine.
So, if you count to nine --
You know how to count, right?
You learn in school, right?
-Yeah, I did. I remember.
-Do you? You remember?
Have trouble counting?
-No.
You want me to count to nine?
-Okay, so let's count slowly.
So, one.
-One.
-There you go. There's one.
-Yep.
-Two.
-Two. Sorry.
-Three.
Four.
Five. Six.
Seven. Eight.
-And then, so, who was the first
President of the United States?
[ Laughter ]
-Don't even tell me.
George Washington. Unbelievable.
Look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow. That's un--
It's unbelievable.
-Did it work?
-Wow. That's amazing.
Yeah, it is. That was amazing.
That's really good.
That's really --
-Can I watch that back?
-No, no.
We don't have time for that.
-Okay.
-But thank you so much
for bringing that trick.
That's amazing.
You really are getting great.
Let's talk about "Los Espookys."
-Yeah.
-Season two.
-Tomorrow on HBO, HBO Max.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-I've been waiting so long
to see this.
-Thanks.
-Gosh, I loved season one.
It is right now 100% fresh on
Rotten Tomatoes, by the way,
if you want to see something
100% fresh.
If you haven't seen it,
can you catch everyone up?
What is the show about?
-So, it's about a group of four
friends who have a business
where they hire themselves out
to scare people.
It's sort of like the opposite
of "Scooby-Doo."
They're like, "Just hire us
and we'll do, like,
hauntings and seances and things
like that."
And it takes place in a sort of
fictional Latin American
country.
-Yeah, was that on purpose?
I'm assuming it was.
Why would you -- why is it --
-Just because there's so many
different accents from all
the different actors and stuff.
We didn't want to have to do,
like, you know, to make it also,
like, exact that you have to
guess where they were from.
It's better to just keep it --
because we had some actors
from Mexico, Panama,
El Salvador.
-On the show before, you've done
many different impressions
and accents.
You've done different states.
I think you did all 50 states
at one point.
Is there any way that --
Can you do some different
Spanish-speaking accents tonight
on our show
and show everyone
the difference?
-I can do some. Let's see.
So, Mexico is
kind of sing-songy.
And it's got a little bit of
drama to it.
So it's a lot like --
[ Speaking Spanish ]
[ Laughter ]
Cuba is -- they sort of hover
around the consonants.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Venezuela is kind of --
The tone of Venezuela is
a little bit like, "Oh, you
shouldn't have done that."
[ Speaking Spanish ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
And so, Colombia is
a little bit like the sort of
Ohio or the Oregon
of South America.
It's almost like
a newscaster Spanish.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
Like leaning in on the S-H.
Chile is a little bit like --
They're almost like saying,
"I don't feel like talking
right now."
They're a little hesitant.
It's almost like Morse code.
Like...
[ Speaking Spanish ]
[ Laughter ]
That kind of thing.
And then Brazil --
Brazil, that's Portuguese.
It's not Spanish. But they're --
[ Speaking foreign language ]
[ Laughter ]
So, like, the feel of it is,
like, "Come to the party."
That's always been in there.
-Yes.
"Come to the --"
-[ Speaking foreign language ]
-That's how you do it
right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aw, thanks. Thanks.
That's close. Yeah, thanks.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Fred Armisen in the new
season of "Los Espookys."
Take a look at this.
-Hello. Good afternoon.
-Hi, how are you?
-Welcome to Sunset Sushi.
-Thank you.
-I'll take that for you?
-No, there's no need.
This is one of those
new self-parking cars.
[ Horn honks ]
♪♪
-Beep, beep.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Beep, beep."
Sad. It's a beautiful thing.
Fred Armisen, everybody.
Season two of "Los Espookys"
premieres tomorrow
on HBO and HBO Max.
-Thank you.
-More with Fred Armisen
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.